[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout hope
everybody's having a great week
if we haven't met yet I'm Rachel Dempsey
I lead our Pro community at posit and so
this is our open space to chat about
data Science Leadership questions
everyone facing and getting to hear
what's going on in the world of data
across different Industries and if this
is your first time here or if you're
watching this recording at some point in
the future
we're here every Thursday at the same
time same place I should start saying
now we are going to take a little break
for July for a little summer vacation
time and there's a lot of people
traveling
but normally we are every Thursday same
time same place
and so together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everybody we love hearing from you all
no matter your level of experience or
industry or area of work
and so it's totally okay to just listen
in here too but you can also jump in the
conversation and ask questions or
provide your own perspective on certain
topics in a variety of ways so you could
jump in by raising your hand on Zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to put a little star next
to it of course if you want me to read
it instead if you're in a coffee shop or
something
and then we also have a slider link
where you can ask questions anonymously
too
and so this will be very important today
because we are doing things a little bit
different here so if you were on a few
maybe this was a few months ago now
where we had a
random opening because one of our
featured leaders was sick we realized
that we really liked this occasional
format of us all being able to just jump
in and be the featured leader
so we are all the featured and leaders
today
um and so I wanted to also
point out that because of that
if you wouldn't mind when you do jump in
or ask a question to just introduce
yourself again too I know some of us
know each other pretty well now from
coming to the Hangouts so it might be
nice to just do some introductions again
too when you jump in and and ask a
question
um
but I can I can kick things off here
with something I'd love to ask
you all about
um
and this is something that's come up in
a few conversations from with with
people who have reached out on LinkedIn
um a lot of times we'll feature
different leaders here that are from
larger companies who have like
established data science teams
and
at the same time there's a lot of people
who might be in the audience who are
building up a data team for the very
first time
and I was just curious to kind of open
the discussion up with that to learn
from you all who are in that position of
building up a data science team
what does that process look like for you
and how might that be different than
working in one of these like large
Fortune 500 organizations
and again feel free to just raise your
hand on Zoom or comment in the the chat
here too
anybody like in the process of just like
starting to build up a data science team
or you're thinking about
building ones
okay uh Rachel's this is George hey
George hey yeah you know this is
actually like the perfect question
um for me because I I started a job
about a month ago and uh first data
scientist in HR uh it's a brand new role
and so kind of tasked with like starting
from scratch with everything so building
out you know metrics defining like
defining metrics and doing data
governance
um learning a new system in HR you know
there's the hris like the main source
and then from there kind of like
developing a team
um so it's like starting from like a
even before I think what you were
talking about which is like starting
with a team it's like even before that
which is but having the mindset of like
this will turn into that you know so
um I think right now it's like just
looking at the different tools that are
out there uh understanding how
we might manage a data Lake and trying
to find the right I think right now
we're kind of just looking at tools
kind of focused on that
yeah how how do you approach that like
knowing what to focus on first then
so far my Approach has been to have
discussions with our HR managers so
those are the the primary stakeholders
or the ones that are going to be
leveraging the data yeah
um and communicating it to either like
higher up or to the different managers
within the organization and also
thinking about security and uh because
with HR data it's highly
you know secure
um yeah the information that we share we
don't always want to share demographics
so also thinking about security policies
but uh just a lot of yeah just a lot of
conversations with with people
um about what their business needs are
I see um I'm just looking over to the
chat here too I see Eugene you had a few
thoughts on this topic do you want to
jump in here
sure I'll I'll Stay High
um
I had to build a team uh you know at a
previous position uh I'm currently a
team of one and hopefully we'll be
building a team soon
um I think the
there are very few unicorns which I put
three things up there like that you
there's a use case and a necessity
um sometimes you need somebody to be
able to build things as fast as possible
so you got to go for a programmer or
people who really know programming who
can build a pipeline who feel they
understand production level stuff okay
I've dabbled in multiple tools etc etc
uh I can't necessarily rely on somebody
like that to be the math genius someone
who understands integration and
probability distributions and difference
between a poisson and an exponential and
la la la
um that person also has a lot of value
and everyone can learn from them too and
sometimes if you're in a place where you
need very sophisticated modeling to sort
of take a leap up uh you need a person
like that probably who can bring in that
extra skill set uh and then there's the
contextual experts and that I'm
currently in a position where I'm not a
contextual expert
um I am in bioinformatics which is my
first foray into the medical field of of
data uh it is the data is more
disgusting in the medical field than
pretty much anywhere I've ever seen by
the way
um but the the contextual expert
probably in this role is more important
than anyone because they're going to be
spending a lot of time trying to figure
out is this a generic drug or is this a
name of a brand or what is an encounter
um why is this all event level data you
know and not something where it's at a
patient level where I can do my
Analytics how do I convert things from
patient level to you know or from event
level to Patient level
um you know like a a contextual expert
would be very very probably the most
useful person I would dive in on if I
had to hire someone in a data science
position uh to underneath me uh in a
team in bioinformatics so to me the
first the first question is really like
what are going to be the highest impact
projects
um and who of those three major skill
sets would I dive in on to try and at
least create a my first employee and
then round out based on their weaknesses
um but I would aim for for trying to
cover those three bases if you're really
going to build a whole team of four or
five six people you really need people
who are in my opinion really good
experts at each at one of those three
things because it's very rare to find
somebody who's an expert in all three
and you'd be paying out you know a ton
of money if you do find someone who's an
expert in all three
yeah
I think that kind of answers your
question you had asked Libby too but do
you want to to ask that to a few others
here in in the group
sure yeah that's the um the sort of
experience that I have with
talking with people and interviewing
people interviewing with people
um is that when they are building a team
they're looking for somebody to hit the
ground running and they always use that
term we need somebody to hit the ground
running and a lot of times what I feel
like they're saying is we need somebody
to do everything and we also need
somebody to tell us what we what to do
because we don't know what to do
and that feels really scary
um because I often think well I'm not
that person I'm a stats person I'm an
applied stats person that's my like side
of the the game I can't be everything
for everybody
um so as a person who
is looking at the industry that freaks
me out it sounds like you guys are also
saying that person doesn't really exist
and my sort of
um take on that is if you have somebody
who does everything and knows everything
they are now your single point of
failure and if they leave something
happens to them all of your expertise
goes in one person and instead of
needing to replace the one person who
was maybe a me or maybe the programming
person you now have nothing so I'm
curious about people's thoughts on
building a team of people who are kind
of
lower level and not those those unicorns
and and how do you make that work what
do you look for
Libby I can't figure out how to raise my
hand right now in Zoom
um
I probably should say that too
um yeah so if anybody looks at the
bottom or it says reactions there's like
a little smiley face oh there it is
sorry I should have put that in there
but thanks Catherine for jumping in yeah
I was in full screen and so that had
gone away
um I feel like a lot of times looking
for people who can hit the ground
running is like corporate code for we
are not going to onboard you or train
you at all I think that's really
something that I think when you are
building a data science team you know
like
they were talking about before you need
to say like these are the people that I
need and the skill sets that they're
going to have and then like build your
onboarding around what that team's going
to look like
um one of the things that that we've
been doing is trying to get away from oh
well this one person knows everything
and so like for six months all we did
was write documentation about our
processes and how and transcribe email
chains from three years ago into things
like that so that when we do bring on
new people we can onboard them not only
on the technical aspect of the job but
also on the context of the data
especially because we're in the medical
field as well where you are bringing on
people who may not have had any medical
experience before
definitely
thank you all for I'm just I'm trying to
read through the chat here for people
who want to comment on a specific topic
too
um Coulter I see that you had shared
when I first said about like starting
your starting the first data science
team that you started a data team and
I'm curious like did you have to build
up the business case for that or were
you hired on to start the the data
science team
yeah hey everyone
um kind of almost both um so I work for
a local government uh public health
department and there was it was
essentially Uncharted Territory when it
comes to data science everything is it
was done in Excel and I I think I kind
of tried to get buy-in on this from a
selfish point of view because I was
doing I was doing all this data and I
was like this this shouldn't take this
long
um we were spending a ton of time trying
to do all this
um so luckily I had great leadership
that said you know what this is that's
right we should start something
um and it started um was able to hire
someone and immediately just trying to
convert everything to our automate as
many things as possible and I love I
guess I'll preface this next part I love
hand washing dishes because the the
catharsis from it and the the first time
that we were able to show someone hey
you know this thing that used to take
you 16 hours it takes 30 seconds now
um and the joy in their face that I will
never forget that
um and I think that really showed
leadership this is something worth
investing in even further
um so that was that was about two and a
half years ago and you know like I said
we're able to hire uh one person to join
and now we are a team of eight and it's
been super awesome uh everything
everybody's already said has been bits
and pieces uh in our experience as well
either from security or just scaling
just things in general so it's been fun
still got a long way to go a lot of cool
stuff to learn
that's awesome
we go from starting the team to eight
now how did you
um figure out like what those roles
should be like those eight people
oh great question I I originally kind of
designed it and someone had just
mentioned this as you know hey this
person maybe focuses on specifically
visualizations
um maybe pipelines that get to a
visualization uh and then realize for
continuity of operation purposes that
wasn't going to be feasible
um so switch to a different method of
almost everybody's kind of trained on
everything and can kind of do stuff if
needed but no one is really expected to
be an expert at every other person's job
because that's that's asking a lot from
people and I don't think as a leader I
don't think anyone should expect every
person on the team to be that expert at
everything
absolutely
I wanted to remind everybody too if you
feel okay or comfortable with it just
introducing yourself to especially for
people who are joining us for the first
time here as well
um
okay let me let me double check and
Curtis and Hannah are helping me
organize questions but anybody else want
to comment on on this topic too
oh Alan I see your hand
baby Liz Allen
Alan can you hear us
I can see you talking Ellen but no sound
come back to Alan
anybody else have have thoughts on on
this like building up your first
data team
is that better yep there you are okay
you know like you turn on your computer
one day and it's like I don't have a
microphone it's a microphone
um uh what was I gonna what was I gonna
talk about
um I think so sort of looking on the
whole sort of circuit from from what
Libby was saying to take Catherine to
Coulter
um I was thinking about it I think I've
had a really experience interesting
experience with my team of
um saying for a number of years like we
need cross support ability for the
things that we're doing and finding that
as the team grows just the demand grows
we have more stakeholder teams that
we're connected with and people end up
being kind of de facto kind of drawn
with dotted lines to those stakeholder
teams and getting kind of specialized in
those Lanes versus
being able to sort of share and cross
support and that's been and that's been
a real challenge because for years I've
wanted to help you know certain folks
who support really high intensity stuff
to have more help
um and I think probably I've had a
combination of like really good luck
getting good people on the team who come
in and are eager to to help to do that
but I think we hit a little bit of a
critical mask with the team where uh
there were enough people and the team is
now six and I have enough people who are
curious and who are skilled who can help
without getting sort of completely
pulled into the pool of of being able to
to cross support
um
and so whether it's like disciplinary or
subject matter expertise
um I really have felt like in the last
year there's been like a Tipping Point
of my team is big enough now that they
can help one another whereas when it was
two they were just like head down
focused on getting stuff done and then
when it was four there was a little more
room but still pretty head down and now
with six there's enough of a of a
cohesive team there that they can share
they can collaborate without me driving
all the collaboration
um it feels like that size has really
opened up a bunch of new opportunity
that I don't think I could have created
with two or three or four people
um and it's got a whole new set of of
you know like working and meeting
challenges but their ability to run has
really taken off in such a cool way in
the last six months since they've
they've kind of got up to speed with one
another
um so I don't know if that leads to uh
you know like a concluding point uh but
but it's been really neat to see that
transition over time as the team has
grown and they've gotten to know one
another develop their skills and develop
their subject matter expertise
um it's been really really fun and
rewarding to see them get good at what
they do and get really good at helping
one another it's really cool
that's great thank you Alan uh Catherine
I see your hands it's raised do you want
to jump in yeah um I I love that from
from Alan because that's sort of
collaborative work really facilitates
the rest of the data science
um
it's something that I've I've struggled
with is you know making sure that people
get credit for doing that where it it
frequently becomes you know unseen work
you're not emailing a spreadsheet to
someone you're not
you know doing that but fostering that
relationship sending you know being
active in your your chat be like sending
out those emails to those teams building
a business use case around something
um
is is so important to staying connected
to the rest of those teams
um and so we have like a strategy for
getting credit for that but like if
anyone else has anything where how do
you one manage that unseen work but also
make sure that the people who are doing
it still get credit for it I'd love to
hear about that
can I ask you Catherine what's your team
strategy for that
um we do something every quarter called
um Take a Bow where we basically have
our members write up and they do it in
our markdown
um but they write out everything that
they think that they did throughout the
quarter
um and then they send that to me and my
sister team manager and we like
aggregate that information and we
escalate it up our reporting pipeline so
it's like it's got the hard details of
the stuff that we did
um you know here's the git lab repo
here's you know the business value that
this created Etc but also I did all
these other things like I was active on
my committee board I like you know
anything else that you're a part of that
you want to make sure that you get
credit for you can escalate that so I
did kind of like Outsource the like
management of that credit but it still
makes sure that that's it it's at least
seen by like one in two levels above the
person who's doing that work
but it's a lot of manual stuff
yeah
somebody had it recommended to me in the
and then our ladies slack group to like
every week send yourself an email of all
the things that you did that week so
then at the end of the year or whenever
you're showing
your leadership team what you did you
remember all those little things and I
think a lot of what I do is sometimes
that glue work that I sometimes forget
like oh that was really important that I
did that and I connected these teams
across the company but if I didn't write
it down for myself I wouldn't
maybe have remembered it or thought it
was as important
any other thoughts on what other teams
are doing to kind of highlight some of
that work
I see Aaron um
you had a comment in the chat here
oh yeah around annual review time
okay Mark I'm curious what's what's your
team's process
sorry I was on mute
um yeah Aaron Aaron said that she in the
chat but she keeps a one note open
um my team I work for a healthcare
system in Houston on a group of analysts
we're really small we have like four of
us on the team so we're really tight
tight-knit but we all have our like
little domain area of expertise uh but
we all share do something similar um the
only difference is we all share that
same one note uh that our manager sees
and we like keep track of um with weekly
one-on-ones so it's a really good way to
just see across the year what you're
working on and then like look back and
see what you've accomplished
definitely I see
um Jeffrey had asked a great question in
the chat I know you don't have a mic at
the moment so I'll I'll read it yeah but
the question was
at what point and how do you decide to
stop focusing on the non-analytics work
that has filled your backlog and push
for more of the advanced Analytics
a lot of our issue is requests come in
and they are dashboards that should be
done by more of a business analyst and
not a data engineer or data scientist
but for us it's difficult to dig out of
that hole or find a stopping point
I see a few comments here in the
thread of that so I'll I'll start with
you Jared if you if you feel like
jumping in here
and sorry if I'm hey Rachel come here oh
there you are yes sorry about that no
worries no yeah I know I think it's just
kind of like he was talking about
further down like chicken or egg if
you're
you're getting to the point where the
work load in the backlog is just
becoming insurmountable how do you
do a more efficient job of of uh
organizing and kind of disseminating
that to push the needle forward instead
of uh just kind of being drowned under
the work so do you take the approach of
trying to split and split the work and
split the the idea of having a focus on
analytics versus non-analytics teams or
are you trying to hire more of those you
know unicorns that can do both sides of
that to uh to help and you know how do
you kind of manage or approach that you
know that's I think that's the big
question for me anyway
I thought something that was interesting
on the like topic of of dashboards is I
think it was
um I'm blanking on who had said this
but if you stopped creating any of those
dashboards like which ones would people
really notice that were missing and like
which ones are we just creating for the
sake of of creating them and updating
them
um I was I was remembering that too from
yeah a couple weeks ago and even going
back to Libby's comment in the chat of
like what's gonna happen if you don't do
that
um and if the answer is you know four
billion dollars of critical business
processes stop then they probably need
to hire someone to make that dashboard
and if the answer is like one guy gets a
little upset then like maybe you don't
make it
really
um Jonathan remmers or Chris
um I see you had some thoughts on this
topic too do you want to jump in here
and see who if anybody on mutes
I was saying that I get frustrated
because
uh descriptive analytics has a bad name
now nobody wants to come into our field
to do descriptive analytics or reporting
but it's actually still very important
um
and you just can encourage yourself if
if the descriptive stuff you're doing is
very important like it's okay and it's
not always easy to put together either
but if you're trying to make that switch
you may have to first convince people of
the value not to say oh we want to do
Advanced analytics they don't understand
what that means but like what's the
outcome that you want to achieve that
you need to go do Advanced analytics to
get to
and some of what I've done internally is
you know talking to to stakeholders in
the company what are their goals what do
they want to know what are questions
that they haven't asked what are
questions they
um don't ask because
they don't want to be disappointed that
there's not an answer uh to I will ask
people to like think without
um think without any restrictions like
don't worry about what we can or can't
do what would you like to see
and then if you can get people who will
Who Would sponsor yeah these are the
these are the outcomes you would like to
get then you have a little more weight
behind that request to try to shift your
time away from descriptive analytics to
something else
thank you
um Gerard I see you have your hand
raised here too to jump in on this topic
yeah I think what um what you just said
is is is critical because getting access
to the data is usually one of the the
harder things to do so if you have an
executive who wants a report or a
dashboard or whatever you can break that
that deadlock in getting access to the
data and once you have it you know you
can you can do the more advanced
analytics and and start to build that
business case of like if we look at it
this way if we do more we can give you
more value but in the end
getting that data and and breaking up
that process of getting the data
processing it and analyzing it in three
different steps it helps in in a variety
of things it helps in building your team
slowly because those are sometimes three
different expertises and you can
potentially
um
give the getting the data to it so that
you don't have to do it so you know it
it opens up time for
um for your own analysis
um it also makes it easier to go back
all the way to the beginning of the
discussion about hitting the ground
running
um you have people who are good at these
three different things and I think when
they describe that they're looking for
people who are hitting the ground
running
are people that can answer that final
question that give that report to the
executive and you know
give that final result
so if you can use that uh from a report
from uh from a straightforward dashboard
if you can use that to break the um the
debt logging and getting access to the
data and start slowly building some
analytics I think that that's a good way
to start
you have to be very careful that I to
also what what people were saying that
it doesn't become your day job and your
only day job you know
can I just confirm with with anybody
here what is descriptive analytics
exactly mean
versus Advanced Analytics
I was thinking there's like this classic
three or four
step thing it's like you have
descriptive and then Diagnostic and then
predictive and then prescriptive that
was like something maybe eight ten years
ago that made the rounds I've seen that
too Chris what I think people when they
say analytics they're talking about
everything to the right of descriptive
on that visual
okay the script is like what what is
going on right now yeah
this is what is happening or has
happened
um
but diagnostic is kind of like what has
happened I think it's just yeah this is
what it is
cool thank you I need to make a bar
graph of I think counts as described as
Analytics
Ralph I see your hands raised here by
the way you just can't do any of those
other three things good at all if you
don't do descriptive analytics yeah
that's what I found with working with
clients is helpful is I actually made an
image of a pyramid where the first layer
is descriptive analytics and then
predictive is smaller and then
prescriptive is on the top and so with
the idea that majority of your time
running your business and most of your
efforts as a data team should be in that
descriptive side because that's the
basis of anything to predict the future
or making large changes in your business
so that's been helpful and then I also
started adding a basement of data
management yeah there's a data quality
layer under there somewhere I call it
the basement even though I don't know if
pyramids have basements
that's great George I see your hands
raised
oh yeah I just wanted to chime in on the
descriptive it um yeah to kind of
reinforce what was said about you know
it's just as important
um and crucial and fundamental and it
made me think of actually this morning I
cracked open my Edward tufty book
um and you know just like in awe over
the descriptive stats that are in there
but the way that they're presented
like they're presented in a way that
solves a problem right like there's the
classic like cholera outbreak
uh map that was done and it's like
that's descriptive analytics but it's
just in a way that's telling a story
it's in a way that's that resonates with
people so it's not necessarily like oh
it's just so simple
um and you know maybe not
not worth our time but it's more like
how do you how do you convey those
descriptive stats
uh it could be as simple as a bar chart
but is that really answering the
question is that really getting to
it could be it could be descriptive
stats that's all they need but
again like how it's conveyed is you know
vital
definitely thank you I'm loving this
Lively discussion here Mike I see your
henries
oh yeah I was just gonna say that I
heard a great talk from a data science
leader I think working for one of the
big supermarkets in the UK who described
descriptive analytics as kind of looking
in the rear view mirror so you know what
has happened
so maybe that's a that's also quite a
good analogy so do people generally use
bi tools for more of descriptive
Analytics
and predictive
and or whatever it's past that is more
of I still have to rngg plot for all of
my descriptive analytics but Power bi is
really powerful too
they will usually rely on business
analysts
um you know to produce dashboards of
descriptive statistics but it doesn't
necessarily ever imply that you're going
to get that extra layer of context as to
maybe why those those stories are taking
place
mm-hmm
I see on the topic of like getting rid
of some dashboards Mark you had a great
question earlier do you want to jump in
here
I think you had to run out oh okay well
the question yeah the question was does
anyone have experience or suggestions
for getting folks to agree to deleting
dashboards Mark said our group has so
many dashboards we maintain with only
slightly different views of the same
data set and I have thus far been unable
to get buy-in even though the technical
debt we've incurred is astounding
I have a few comments on this
um we just
I so I'm at centene along with Catherine
who's mentioned uh you know who's talked
a bit this morning uh but we have like
75 000 employees or so and I actually
just helped run a hackathon for anyone
that wanted to participate at the
company and
um the whole purpose the whole problem
statement was effectively what can we do
about our dashboard craze situation and
believe it or not like outside of this
hackathon since January 1st there have
been about 25
000 dashboards that have been deleted
so the idea is like
what is going on with so many dashboards
and reports that are now all on the
cloud
um
and so
yeah it's a serious problem and I I
don't think that
um for larger corporations at least I
don't I kind of feel like the thought
has been just create a dashboard if it's
not used like don't even really think
about it you know if it if if like
yeah if we need to delete this later we
can no big deal but there's costs
associated with all this and the
resources that are used to just keep
those online
um
so yeah this this this whole hackathon
was done to really try and drill in on
like can we put some strategy behind a
rationalization approach or some kind of
decommissioning approach or strategy to
all these different
um
you know reports and dashboards that the
company has and it's not just I'm not
just talking like 25 000 shiny apps
would be incredible I'm talking more
like
um you know reports and dashboards
across all of our platforms power bi
Tableau micro strategy Etc
the hackathon
too yeah the winners did an excellent
job coming out with kind of a solution
that had more of that like prescriptive
um insights for leadership
um so I'm really excited to see what we
do about maybe productionizing that as
kind of a shiny app or something like
this for leadership to to have a clear
visibility into like
how many how many reports you know
should be on a decommissioning path or
et cetera yeah
honest I see your hands raised do you
want to jump sure so I guess one gentle
way to
um to test the waters for governance for
some of these dashboards just
um you know if it gets updated on a
constant basis try one period to not
update it or one month not to update it
and see what reactions you get and if
it's a live feed try to cut it off and
see what reactions you get now if no one
says anything and they're not really
paying attention to it then that's a
good sign and you can say okay this is
probably not being used
um as much as it should as it should be
or as much as expected but obviously if
you hear people uh Express their descent
and say no we rely on this data then
that's a good indicator to say that the
dashboard is so relevant and uh you know
the consumer it's it's stakeholders
still need it to be in place and active
thank you
I see um Abigail you have your hand your
varies here too do you want to jump to
the next
yeah so we monitored our usage of
dashboards I mean like that's really the
start like we templo has apis
um I don't know what other tools have
but like you can see who's looking at
your dashboards and when and so being
able to go in with like nobody's looked
at this in three months like that's a
really strong argument like literally
nobody's using this um and even then
nobody wanted anything deleted but we
were able to get permission to hide
basically hide dashboards nobody was
using except for people who are actually
building the dashboards write some
documentation that says what all the
ones that aren't hibernation should do
so like in the future if somebody wants
to bring it back they can read that and
say oh I needed this but it's not
something that we're having to worry
about maintaining on a regular basis
yeah
do you think sometimes it's that like
the dashboard or whatever visualization
was really helpful for someone when they
first saw it but then they don't know
where to ever find it again
no because nobody's looked at them three
months I think people just really get
freaked out by the interview they're
like
they're like so like we're not we
promise we're not getting rid of it it
will still exist if you ever need it I
think like the safety thing even though
really somebody are never an ever coming
back
George I see you have your hand raised
here too you want to jump in
Yeah we actually did that uh with the
dashboard because we actually it was a
power bi dashboard and tells you when it
gives us reports that no one's using it
and uh so we decided to stop updating it
and found that okay they actually did
need it but not as frequently uh and so
I think like just going back to the
requirements for building it and
understanding you know the frequency of
of that and so just having a discussion
about like what were the expectations so
realizing oh they really only needed
like once a quarter but you know we've
built it in a way that could be done
like every day like you know but we
didn't need to update the data every day
so you know sometimes
um it's just understanding the uh the
requirements and not necessarily going
to think well they don't they don't ever
use it well when they use it it's super
important
it's just not frequent
absolutely
I uh I see all this fun chat happening
during the The Hangout too and I am
jealous I don't get to read it but I'm
going to read that all after too I love
to see the the party happening there
um but there was a slido question
someone had asked anonymously
I try to save code tips that I can see
uses for in later projects but I feel
like it's so messy how do you all keep
track of frequently used code notes and
tips
so I didn't think you'd see it in time
before someone else started talking
um I so I have to I work in Python
almost exclusively like at work and I
think I I think I mentioned that before
um and you know we do a lot of Jupiter
notebooks for interactive things which I
know people have a lot of feelings about
but I am determined to put as much code
as I can into GitHub so we have a we get
a repositories for our main like
production things that are controlled we
have our team has a big team a big
pricing team has a
a repository that's basically scripts
and some of the scripts can be things
that we run automatically but some of
them are just like it's just a possible
that anyone can push to and so if I
write anything that I think is cool and
then I want to use later and I think
anyone else will have any benefit of I
will put it into like a utility scripts
folder in there and it's version
controlled and people I'll tell people
about it and then other people sometimes
will contribute to it and then I also
have my own little secret private Marcus
repo uh where something isn't quite
baked enough for to share with everyone
I will save into my own repository and
so Version Control
um and git and GitHub if you have access
to those tools are a really good way to
not lose uh stuff into some 105 or
someone else Jupiter notebook or
whatever and so my strategy is to write
as much as I can inside an editor and
save it into a git control code file and
then if I need to use it in a notebook I
will import it into my notebook which
you can do with python pretty easily
um that I'm not exactly sure how I'll be
our folks think about this
um since I I have a stereo actually when
I use RMS terrible overriding functions
um but um uh that's kind of my strategy
um so if you haven't learned about git
and Version Control highly recommend
um either chatting with other folks here
or
um
or just uh yeah trying to learn more
about it
Okay I uh one resources I know is like
the Happy get with our
um book if anybody wanted to share that
in the chat but Eugene I see you have
your your hand raised yeah functions
functions functions functions just
functionalize it give it a descriptive
name put it in your in somewhere that I
I created a company uh R repo you know
or our package
um just titled it the company name
everybody had a copy of it everybody
could make edits everybody could update
those edits and every single function
was it just became more and more
generalized which is the best thing
about writing functions and and forcing
that everybody writes functions and you
can't finish writing your function
unless you actually create a manual page
and which is the best part about it so I
know it takes you know an extra 10
minutes and uh such a hassle you know to
add that three sentences of
documentation that describe the
arguments and what you want to use it
for but I mean the overall build of
productivity over time is just you know
nobody has to resolve the same problems
we all have to convert dates we all have
to convert zip codes we all have to add
leading zeros we all convert things from
factors to Strings or strings to factors
Etc account the number of factors like
just build functions that do this stuff
just build them and leave them there and
anytime anybody has a problem like this
you know in your team meeting you say
hey what new functions were added this
past week it's very simple to get that
sort of it's exponential productivity
that you'll get across the the team
do we need a data science hangout GitHub
and packages
um Catherine I see your hand raised here
yeah I was just going to comment that
like even if you're not on
like a full data science team and an
organization that has git lab and our
professional tools like before I was at
centene I was the only R user and a data
science team of one and I basically made
a setup script for myself that had some
of my most helpful functions in it and
in my little profile I said
put all these in my session at startup
and so it was it was a function for
dealing with dates in the format that I
knew that they came from my database and
things like that like even if you're
just doing it for you it's still a good
practice and then if you do onboard more
people and you start share you can share
that script with them and then
eventually make that business case like
hey we do need a get lab license so that
we can share these things as our team
grows and as our organization grows like
and if it does still just be you you've
made your own life better
of course yeah thank you all for the the
thoughts here too before leaving this
topic I was kind of reminding
myself I think Mike Smith you talked
about this by using like Snippets too
yeah you know Snippets are fabulous
right because you you kind of give a
little shortcut and then it gives you a
skeleton or framework where you can jump
into certain parts within that framework
and kind of almost also complete certain
sections
um you can
you can share Snippets there's use this
allows you you know has a way of opening
up the Snippets so that you can uh edit
them
um
but you know
so for things that you do frequently and
where you actually have that framework
they're really really helpful
um but I think I'm leaning more towards
what's just been said about right right
functions right
because it's like you can also then
document those test them you can roll
them up into a package
for some reason writing a function it
just sounds scarier to me than the word
snippet well it does because writing a
function implies that you're going to
write the documentation then you're
going to maintain it forever
right whereas a snippet well it's a bit
more throwaway right
yeah I think just a point to add to this
um this is something that try to do my
company is also sharing that you've done
this with others making sure it's on
your knowledge based solution because
then you find out oh this has already
been done by somebody else and I didn't
have to put all this effort if they'd
only share it
um so I think contributing to the
community is important internally just
as well as it is externally
I see there was a question Israel you
had asked is there a place that posits
shares functions created by the
community
and Curtis you had some thoughts there
do you want to jump in
or Curtis I'm putting you on the spot
there sorry I just thought you had
commented on there I was kind of half
joking trying to do it light-hearted but
like that's usually what packages and
you know trusted GitHub repos are for
but I see the point you know there's
this kind of middle ground or like lower
ground uh with like a cookbook type
thing uh so like the first book I ever
bought related to R was uh the ggpa two
cookbook which is literally just a
collection of great tips for jujuba too
so I totally see the value
foreign
go back to see some questions or maybe
had missed
um
oh Olivia I saw it earlier you had a
question around collaboration
do you want to ask that one
did I um I was probably about time like
it there's a conversation around like we
really want people to collaborate and
how do we get them to talk to each other
and how do we get them to form a
community and be more connected because
we're all remote and my question is
do they have the time to do that because
if they don't you are expecting
something magical like it's not going to
happen
um and so the the push that I'm
that I'm trying to you know go for is
like prioritize
timing prioritize chunks of people's
time for that stuff if you don't tell
them to do it and that you want them to
do it give them the time to do it
it's probably not gonna happen because
they're gonna be heads down
um and feeling too pressured and I was
thinking about there was a Harvard
Business review article that I read
recently about capacity about how people
do their best work when they're actually
about 85 capacity or 80 capacity not 100
and
aiming for people to be at 80 or 85 does
free them up a little bit to have the
mental and emotional capacity to connect
with other human beings to share stuff
and
we have all this double work and we have
all these silos guess what if people
talk to each other those walls start to
break down and you start to realize
other people are duplicating work and
you start to realize what's possible
because someone says oh yeah I did that
in this other project and maybe it's not
the exact same thing but it's going to
help so
that's my that's my two cents I guess
less of a question but
are you prioritizing your people having
that time
I love that thank you Libby and I think
Mike has some thoughts to share on it
sorry for being the guy that jumps in
here but
um you don't have to be sorry the I've
I've been the our guy at our company for
uh many many many years
and before we really go our our
community going
everyone came to me oh Michael know the
answer to this oh Michael help me to
solve out these installation issues oh
Michael help me answer this tricky
question I've got about how to do this
thing
so and that then funnels everyone in
through me
you know and and that you might argue
that that's great for my brand but it's
you know making me Beyond 100 capacity
and then it's hard to keep up with all
the requests and it means that I have
the same question again and again and
again and again and again and it gets
really tedious because even though I
bang about it and go you must do it this
way everyone's so busy and they're like
this and and it never gets through once
we have the community in place
we have a single source of here's the
information on how to install R here's
the information on how to you know get
the packages you need here's you know we
have that place for the the written
documentation we have our community
sessions that say if anyone's got
questions
they come in through that Community page
and anyone can answer that question
right so
it's absolutely vital that the community
gets going because otherwise it all
funnels through your Regional local
Friendly RX bear
and that person just winds up burning
out
so you know it's it's kind of you know
we've been talking about the ROI on
taking time to build community but
without it you're gonna have you know
someone's gonna burn out because they're
at the sharp end of that funnel
sorry uh voice of experience and and
also feeling thankful that my sport team
is there and we're building Community
every day so
take out the SWAT team
that's great
yeah big uh
kudos to the the Pfizer team there and
all the the different Community efforts
you lead
um Gerard I see your hand went up on
this topic yeah so uh when covet hit and
everybody started working from home what
we did was uh I established tea time a
couple of times a week for the team to
get together and there was a there was a
very simple rule you were only asked to
uh talk about work related things in the
last five minutes
um but it really helped to have that
interpersonal connection with the people
in the team and so you kind of knew if
they were stressed if they were doing
something fun at home or whatever and
then in those last couple of minutes you
could quickly ask you know what they
were working on that did anyone need any
help
um you know do we need to make any
connections uh between different teams
um and so to uh to to Libby's Point yeah
that the more you
um if you don't force it you know those
conversations don't happen and and like
because the first couple of weeks of
Cove had no one talked to each other
like everybody was just doing work and
and uh that just didn't work
um so uh after initiating that tea time
uh that at least that forced
conversation uh really helped in in
multiple ways not just socially but also
um in in keeping that collaboration and
that networking going
I'm thinking about how we sometimes
we've talked about like the power of
automating something that was once
manual and how that helps you like
exponentially down the road
but it's almost the same with the
community efforts like you need to take
a chance to like step back and look at
the big picture and create that
community so that it can help everybody
later on down the road and that you're
not just the one person who everybody's
going to for questions
and that there's so many others that are
supporting each other
Eugene I see your hand is raised too
yeah I mean
this it's an interesting concept that
the documentation and the building
functions for a team and having your
team iterate on the functions
um I don't think people recognize that
that is its own collaboration it begins
literally the collaboration you I
remember when I was hired
um at really like my first management
gig and I I walked in on the bar code
that they were using and everybody was
on a different version of our and
everybody was using different versions
of packages and everybody had three or
four different templates to do basically
a similar version of the exact same
analysis uh there's worked for them they
had certain functions that had certain
edits for them for one of these
particular use cases I mean it was
terrible in terms of overall
productivity and building models took
literally three days and it took me
about six months to a year but in a year
I had people building models in for
instead of three days right and we were
all using the exact same R version and
we were all using Snippets of functions
that slowly got better because somebody
finally put it put one into a package
and when somebody checked out that
function and actually did something with
it it broke for them because they were
using a slightly alternative use case so
what did we teach them to do you add a
new argument and then having that new
argument you add that to the
documentation and then on the bottom you
have these edits you make that you just
add an if else statement you know based
on that new argument and now the
function does both things for both
people
um and and this literally began the
collaborative process uh and there were
you know people who took two years to
finally check in their own brand new
function even though they were making
edits of functions in the meantime and
it was a big you know yay Amanda Finally
checked in her first function
you know and and the package grew and
more use cases were handled and the and
our entire library of code got better
um and our ability to talk to each other
hey didn't you build something that did
that didn't you build something that you
know solved a similar problem
um and if it doesn't do the exact same
thing you do you know you get to be the
unit tester and figure out how it works
and then you build experience with Git
now your resume grows because you have
experience working with repos you have
experience working with Version Control
you've experienced modifying functions
automating your work all these things
are like you're solving the
collaboration problem you're solving a
productivity problem you're solving
um you know the ability to actually
contribute and build these skill sets
that every future job is going to need
from you I mean the whole thing is
literally like you can solve in my
opinion multiple problems just by trying
to centralize your code and get
everybody to work together on similar
codes similar projects
um you know and it doesn't even have to
be similar but we're all data scientists
and we have to be like you know wild
people
um sometimes writing SQL parsers and
then suddenly you can talk to the
database people and they build a
scripting function that builds a SQL
parser builds SQL queries for them with
a few arguments and we had that
experience of being able to finally hand
off
SQL queries or SQL query Builders like
to our own business analyst that worked
in SQL all day and yes R we used R to to
staple all this text together and build
SQL queries and they were just amazed
they were like oh this is how you guys
get that done so fast yes and you can do
it too you know
I love that I love how passionate you
are about it but also that yes and you
can do it too
um one last question I wanted to ask I
see Priyanka asked a question that is
kind of on the same topic around making
time for Community but for the team
Builders and leaders here how do you
encourage your teams to keep up Skilling
while continuing the business as usual
I'm really lucky I have Sam Palmer on
the team and he's he contributes to our
weekly and so you know it's part of I
see that as part of his job too you know
it used to be a hobby now it's actually
part of his job but some collates that
information anyway but then internally
they produce a little kind of monthly
blog post to say you know what we're
seeing is the latest greatest and that
helps enormously
that's great any any other thoughts
and encouraging your teams to keep up
Skilling
I'm gonna say the same thing that I did
for Community stuff which is like put
that time into people's
reviews and into their weeks like I've
had jobs where it's expected that 10 of
my time is upskilling and I need to be
able to talk about it I need to be able
to say like this month I use 10 of my
time to do X Y and Z and as if it's a
part of the accountability for somebody
then they know that they're allowed to
do it
and yeah it's hard though right back
back to also what um was said earlier
that
you know your your focus on your day job
to get stuff done and off your desk and
out the door
means that it's hard to assign time to
learn
I was just thinking there that we have
people who learned base are
you know like 15 years ago and they
haven't even got to the Tidy verse yet
and then we've got other people who
learned the Tidy verse five years ago
and aren't aware of the the kind of you
know most recent changes to functions
and so it's it you know you've got to
keep that ball rolling and and
continuous Improvement
um
and just kind of keep chucking it under
people's noses
I like the ideas of like actually
putting in on your calendar I see Tony
you mentioned you're encouraged to use
two hours per week upskilling
I've been thinking about this with
um I talked with our President yesterday
about sometimes I have a tendency to
want to focus on a lot of things and a
lot of different ideas and making things
better but it's also important to like
pick what is the most important thing
that I want to focus on and trying to
like block a whole day for that
um just as dedicated focused time Tony I
think do you want to add something there
uh yes it's um it doesn't always happen
but if um if you can have that goal and
maybe put two hours on your calendar
um especially if if you have a remote
work day
um and can avoid having meetings during
that time
um a lot of times
it seems hard to do because of the
immediate needs the fires that you have
to put out
but getting
it could pay off in the long run because
something could take a lot less time
um when you because you've already got
that Baseline of knowledge and on
whatever skill it is you need so it's
it's definitely worth it if you can if
you can find a way to fit it into your
schedule
apparently and George I see your hands
raised too
yeah I wanted to share my latest uh tip
or trick for upskilling I I'm going back
to the old days of using RSS feeds
in my Outlook
and uh something that you know he used
to see back in like a long time ago 90s
and early 2000s so now I get our
bloggers and a lot of other resources
sent directly to my Outlook application
and you know every time you see that
little number saying how many unread
messages you have I know like okay
there's another article I'm going to
keep up with and that's that's been
really really helpful for me lately
it's a great tip well I know we are a
little bit over on our our time here but
thank you all so much for jumping in the
conversation today and being the
featured leaders here I love to see all
of this
the chat happening as well and I'm
excited to go read that later but thank
you all again so much for for joining us
here today
um and I wanted to let everybody know
that next week
um Joe Chang our CTO at posit will be
our featured leader Joe's the creator of
shiny and that will be our uh the last
hangout before our summer break so we'll
be off from Hangouts for July we'll be
back the first week of August
um so yeah next next week with Joe Chang
hope to see you there too bye everybody